lugo qui nous l'a quittée jeff nous à
rejoindre merci jack pdf qui est un pote
un voilà que j'aime qui est je crois
qu'il était le plus proche de jean paul
qui a toujours été avec lui depuis des
années et des années
je sais que tu le regardes tous les
soirs avec les patinoires
j'ai appelé sa famille pour demander
l'autorisation de venir par les gens
peuvent pas jouer pas le faire ça en
temps normal bien sûr j'étais encore la
veille cuir et
voilà en tout cas elle est partie
entourée des siens mais je pense très
très fort à sa famille ce soir aussi
parce que même si on est tous à tous un
peu orphelins
c'est à paul à florence à stella ses
petits-enfants à son frère sa soeur anna
muriel
et
voilà en tout cas il et
il est parti
heureux entouré des siens c'est ce que
veut dire voilà je sais que cet été déjà
il était
son état de santé se dégrade et qui
reste avec lui tout le temps newey l'été
c'était un grand monsieur qui arrive
match un jeu par an très parlante dans
les détails par rapport à sa blessure
moi je veux surtout parler du soleil de
mai le monde ou quoi c'était ça ou tu
l'a connu taux direct parce que dirait
que tu vois non mais c'est incroyable
parce que vous étiez tout le temps sont
tout le temps son je les rencontrais
grâce à georges lautner le cinéaste qui
a fait nettement vainqueur mais un jour
il me dit tu vas chercher un pote à moi
au martinez j'ai dit c'est qui ton pote
ministre jean paul belmondo
et je vais chercher mon idole de
toujours et je me suis lié d'amitié avec
lui on a fait deux docks ensemble et
puis on a passé nos le cas dernier
quinze dernières années de sa vie on a
passé de nos vacances que celle alexia
bloquant ils sont très curieux de
rencontrer souvent le mieux sur gan et
sam il a connu bien avant moi puisqu'il
effet l'aîné des ferchaux avec lui mais
voilà si je veux dire quelque chose
c'est que c'était un mec immense malgré
son statut et qui avait toujours le le
respect du public l'amour des gens et
malgré sur l'état de physique qui
étaient étaient fatigués quand tu
t'appelais demandaient toujours quand tu
allais alors que c'était lui qui était
cadet plutôt fatiguée et s'était voilà
c'était un mec immense qui
qui prenait toujours cinq minutes pour
les gens de journée je l'aï vu faire des
trucs mais tu peux pas imaginer on
rentre à un soir à minuit à l'hôtel
martinez sous la pluie on rentrera
l'ascenseur il ya un mec qui arrive en
courant ni monsieur belmondo j'ai vu on
fête l'anniversaire mon frère en face
c'est ce qu'on pouvait lui souhaiter bon
anniversaire et jean-paul malgré l'heure
tardive mallegol handicap il ressort de
l'hôtel et ont traversé la rue pour les
souhaiter bon anniversaire à maquiller
connais même pas bien sûr c'était là
jean paul c'est fait j'ai du mal à me
parler au passé comme c'est un soleil et
je pense que le public lui rendait bien
par miracle le voyage vous dit jeff
c'est vraiment le plus proche de
jean-paul sur ces dernières années je
sais que vous étiez tout le temps tout
le temps ensemble comment il était ces
derniers temps hier y est voilà il était
malade et diminuée mais je peux et a
diminué voilà été un peu plus fatigué je
dis voilà cc l'année et c'est la vraie
jean charles est parti aussi cher payé
son super programme d'aidé souvent jean
pas une gtc les chaises musicales là
j'ai tous mes potes qui partent donc
c'était marielle rochefort il ya la
bruche arlon il ya deux ans ça fera deux
ans de résidence à bestiaux ferlo
récemment claude brasseur robert hossein
rémy julienne et
voilà il est arrivé interio greenshows
mais c'est un tel héros pour notre
génération jean-paul on pense qu'il est
immortel cosan highlander même c'est ça
c'est un super héros et moi je vais
garder sa joie de vivre et son soleil
qui avant lui quoi on trouve quatre mois
c'est ce qui m'a c'est ce qu'il
inculquait direct à du veau vit des
moments incroyables avec lui et j'aurai
passé d'une vie pour tout raconter mais
c'est surtout c'est quelqu'un qui était
très bons conseils est ce que quelqu'un
avait vu il a eu ses envies ben bongo
quoi tu vois et je sais que vous parliez
tout à l'heure de ses partenaires
féminines et mais surtout quelqu'un qui
avait le respect des gens malgré son
statut et prenez jamais pour une star un
jour claude lelouch va dire ben
allemande où c'est une star il a un
passeport de stars ni s'en sert jamais
comme en a d'autres et souvent c'est
vrai quand je vois des acteurs au bout
de trois autographes salle et gonfle
jean-paul je les lui faire on était face
à 4 100 légionnaires il a fait 400
autographes 400 photos il ya quatre ans
de ça et puis c
zinédine zidane qui m'a dit un jour
qu'on soit chômeurs ouvriers chefs
d'entreprise cadres hommes politiques
riches pauvres on aime tous belmondo on
est tous des enfants de belmondo et
c'est tellement vrai parce que jean paul
et toucher toutes les classes sociales
c'était à l'époque c'était un événement
finalement donc sorti au cinéma
aujourd'hui c'est plein d'événements le
film qui sort en salles c'est vrai
c'était chaque film de belmondo sans
doute fait naître avec de funès dos
c'est vrai c'était
si je veux dire quelque chose de lui
c'était c'est un soleil permanent jean
paul voilà alors il s'est éteint
aujourd'hui mais
c'est quelqu'un qui va rester voilà qui
restait dans l'histoire du cinéma comme
comme gabin comme fernandel et voilà on
est tous je pense un peu orphelins ce
que redoutait ce moment
bah je le savais je le mettais préparer
parce que tu étais vraiment voilà tout
le temps avec lui c'est ouais c'était on
s'y attendait un communiqué sur rien
évidemment ce n'est pas à nous de le
faire et on savait que ça allait arriver
malheureusement voilà c'est arrivé
aujourd'hui jeudi j'étais encore avec
lui hier et l'embrasser avant de partir
et voilà mais en tout cas sa famille a
été très pro joly voilà et c'est à eux
que je pense ce soir parce que parce que
même si on a été on est tous un peu
touchés aujourd'hui je pense quand on
est le soin ses petits-enfants ses
enfants son frère et sa soeur
celle je pense le plus élevé